Громадський транспорт - одна з візитівок
німецької столиці. А разом із тим -
і одна з переваг проживання тут.
Цьогоріч Берлін навіть очолив міжнародний
рейтинг громадського транспорту. Як стверджують
дослідники з Політехнічного університету в італійському Турині,
порівнюючи розклади міського і приміського
громадського транспорту в понад 30 містах Європи,
Північної Америки та Австралії, саме в Берліні
доїхати з пункта А в пункт Б найлегше і найшвидше.
А точніше - швидше на 20!
Яким же чином берлінцям вдалося цього досягти?
Це колись Берлін намагався підлаштуватися
під тиск невпинного зростання кількості автівок.
Нині ж перевага надається
громадському транспорту та витісненню
приватних машин, особливо з центру міста.
Принцип, за яким формується система
громадського транспорту в німецькій столиці:
щонайменше 80% берлінців у радіусі 400 метрів удень
і 500 метрів уночі повинні мати змогу скористатися
тим чи іншим видом громадського транспорту.
Окрім того, шлях від центра Берліна
до будь-якої зупинки в межах міста має тривати не більше години.
Реклама муніципального BVG -
"Берлінського транспортного підприємства" -
так і запевняє:
ми врятуємо вас і вивеземо з будь-якого району столиці.
Автобуси, трамваї, метро, міські електрички
та приміські потяги Берліна мають спільну мережу
в майже 1900 кілометрів та понад 3000 зупинок.
Самі берлінці з властивою німцям прискіпливістю
часто невдоволені своїм громадським транспортом.
Мовляв, він запізнюється, брудний, надто шумний,
надто старий, надто повільний, надто швидкий,
а оголошення незрозумілі.
Проте муніципальники не ображаються,
кажуть: "Без драми немає любові"
і знімають рекламу про те, що все одно люблять своїх пасажирів.
Водночас, за опитуваннями мерії Берліна,
серед головних факторів, чому люди
віддають перевагу саме громадському транспорту, -
зручність, безпека, швидкість і підйомні ціни на проїзд.
Громадський транспорт Берліна готовий везти
кого завгодно й куди завгодно.
Головне - щоб пасажири платили.
Це майже офіційне гасло,
адже, щоб усе працювало як годинник, потрібні гроші.
До 2035-го на транспортну інфраструктуру Берліна
щороку планують витрачати по 2 мільярди євро.
Це більше, ніж річний бюджет Києва.
Гроші йдуть на оновлення інфраструктури
і кращу її організацію.
Міська влада частково дотує громадський транспорт,
але значною мірою транспортники заробляють гроші самостійно.
Приміром, одноразовий проїзд у Берліні коштує
від 1,70 євро за коротку поїзду, а
місячний проїзний квиток без пільг - 100 євро 50 центів.
Ціна залежить не від виду транспорту,
а від віддаленості кінцевої цілі.
У Берліні існують три зони: зона А - центр міста,
зона В простягається на майже решту столиці,
а в зону С входить передмістя з аеропортом Шенефельд.
Якщо їхати недалеко, можна купити
дешевий квиток на коротку дистанцію -
від трьох до шести зупинок.
Нормальний квиток діє в середньому 1,5 години
в одному напрямку і з ним ви можете безліч разів пересідати.
Також можна придбати квиток на день, на тиждень,
місяць або рік. Розібратися з усім цим допомагають
сайти транспортних підприємств
і зручні додатки для смартфонів.
Щороку майже мільярд людей користується
автобусами, метро та трамваями Берліна.
Щоденний пасажиропотік
"Берлінського транспортного підприємства"
сягає майже трьох мільйонів людей.